a medida que exploramos el mundo de la
estadística vale la pena preguntarnos
qué significa realmente estadística
verdad la estadística muy bien en en
realidad es una categoría muy amplia de
cosas que podemos hacer con datos ok
entonces en realidad la estadística con
lo que va a trabajar es con datos muy
bien entonces por ejemplo podríamos
pensar en que los datos primero hay que
recolectar los verdad recolectar los
podríamos hacer alguna encuesta algunas
preguntas a nuestros conocidos algún
muestreo en fin datos de algún
laboratorio podríamos hacer muchas cosas
para recolectar datos la otra cosa que
tenemos que hacer con los datos es
presentarlos verdad por ejemplo
tendríamos que entregarle a nuestro
profesor oa lo mejor algún familiar oa
nuestro jefe en el trabajo alguna
gráfica que represente los datos o
alguna forma visual para poder ver los
demás
era amigable y la otra cosa que hay que
hacer con los datos por ejemplo sería
analizarlos verdad por ejemplo estimar
si los datos nos están diciendo si hay
algún problema si vamos mejorando en
alguna estrategia a lo mejor nuestras
calificaciones nos pueden ayudar a
analizar si vamos mejorando con nuestros
hábitos y por supuesto hay conceptos
importantes relacionados con la
estadística y uno de ellos es el
concepto de la variabilidad muy bien el
concepto de la variabilidad es un
concepto muy importante en estadística y
quizás en la vida cotidiana podríamos
pensar en la variabilidad como como que
tanto cambiar algo verdad eso es como la
idea intuitiva
y no te debería sorprender que en la
estadística tenemos la misma idea verdad
por supuesto que la variabilidad nos
dice digamos en qué grado o qué en qué
grado se diferencian los datos muy bien
por supuesto esto puede ser una pregunta
bastante complicada si el si el fenómeno
o si el evento del que estemos hablando
puede ser complicado así que vamos a ver
un ejemplo de cuando es algo variable y
cuando alguno entonces digamos que
salimos a la calle y le preguntamos a
cinco personas
cuántos ladrillos se han comido el día
de hoy y entonces tú te pregunta tú tú
dirás a lo mejor qué es una pregunta muy
rara verdad y entonces tú le haces la
pregunta a la primera persona y te dice
no yo jamás me atrevería a comer un
ladrillo y te dice que cero verdad le
preguntas a una segunda persona y te
dice que alguna vez quizás no lo quiso
probar pero no se animó verdad
a lo mejor hay otra persona que te dice
que no nunca ha comido ladrillos y así
preguntas a cinco en total y todos te
dicen que nunca han comido
muy bien entonces aquí podemos ver que
no hay variabilidad verdad el grado
digamos en lo que cambian es nulo no no
hay ningún cambio ok pero digamos que
ahora le preguntas a cinco personas
cuántas uvas se comieron el día de hoy
digamos que a lo mejor la primera
persona te dice no pues yo ni siquiera
desayuné hoy así que digamos eso sería
cero verdad
a lo mejor hay una persona que es
dependiente o es adicta a las uvas y te
dice no yo hoy desayuné 238 uvas a lo
mejor la tercera persona te dice bueno a
mí me gustan las uvas pero tampoco tanto
yo solo me he comido 17 uvas ya lo mejor
le preguntas a otra persona se ha comido
uvas y te dicen si mi ensalada tenía 5
uvas y finalmente te encuentras a otra
persona que es un come uvas y te dice
que se ha comido 318 uvas el día de hoy
muy bien entonces podríamos comparar
estas estas dos listas de datos verdad y
podríamos concluir digamos de forma muy
rápida que la segunda lista está
tenemos aquí resulta ser más variable o
tiene una mayor variabilidad que la
primera verdad esencialmente si están
cambiando los datos digamos entre ellos
verdad en el primer cero 238 luego 17
entonces hay más variabilidad y eso nos
lleva a la pregunta bueno como medimos
la variabilidad que tanto es que tan
variable es una lista respecto a otra o
en qué grado verdad todo eso nos da
bastantes herramientas estadísticas y
para poner a nuestro cerebro digamos en
en un modo estadístico debemos
preguntarnos realmente cuáles son las
preguntas estadísticas verdad así
podríamos ir sacando nuestras
herramientas que vamos generando y
tratar de responder las preguntas que
nos aquejan verdad entonces la pregunta
fundamental primero es cuáles son las
preguntas estadísticas
preguntas estadísticas y en realidad
nosotros vamos a dar una definición aquí
que son aquellas que para responderlas
para responderlas vamos a necesitar de
una serie de datos o una colección de
datos necesitamos
vamos a recolectar datos con
variabilidad recolectar datos
variabilidad muy bien esas son las
preguntas que podríamos decir que son
preguntas estadísticas muy bien entonces
a lo mejor tuve en este momento me dices
tiene sentido la definición pero quizás
me gustaría ver ejemplos que sean más
tangibles de preguntas estadísticas y
otros ejemplos que no sean preguntas
estadísticas yo te diré muy bien tienes
toda la razón vamos a verlo
así que aquí hay seis preguntas y te
invito a que hagas una pausa para que
basados digamos en la definición que
hemos dado de preguntas estadísticas
trates de determinar si estas preguntas
corresponden a una pregunta estadística
o si no son una pregunta estadística
verdad cuáles requieren herramientas de
estadística para responderlas
así que supongo que ya tomaste un tiempo
para pensarlo vamos a analizarlos juntos
muy bien así que la primera pregunta
dice cuánto pesa mi toronja mascota y
por supuesto le quitará de esto puede
resultar bastante raro porque quien
tendría una toronja mascota pues bueno
quizás esta persona tiene justamente su
toronja mascota y resulta que pesa un
kilogramo digamos que pesará un
kilogramo muy bien entonces a lo mejor
alguien podría argumentar bueno es que
tú tuviste que recolectar los datos
verdad tuviste que ir con tu toronja
pesarla y resultó que tenía un peso de
un poco más bien tenía si pesaba un
kilogramo verdad y sin embargo aquí hay
un detalle muy importante y es que no
hay variabilidad esto solo es un dato
así que no podríamos tener variabilidad
y como no tenemos variabilidad no puede
ser una pregunta estadística a lo mejor
si tuvieras varias toronjas verdad y una
pesar a un kilo y otra pesará medio kilo
otra pesará de 750 gramos entonces sí
podríamos hablar de variabilidad verdad
pero esta toronja sólo es una y no hay
variabilidad veamos el siguiente ejemplo
dice cuál es el número promedio de autos
en un estacionamiento los lunes por la
mañana muy bien entonces para tratar de
responder esa pregunta que tendríamos
que hacer bueno tendríamos que
levantarnos temprano verdad e ir todos
los lunes durante digamos no sé a lo
mejor un mes o durante tres meses irá a
un estacionamiento en particular e ir
contando los autos verdad podría ser que
el primer lunes que vamos hay 50 autos
estacionados digamos que al siguiente
lunes hay 49 después puede haber 50 y
después puede haber 63 autos
estacionados verdad entonces podemos
observar que esta pregunta si es
estadística verdad porque tenemos datos
con variabilidad entonces esta pregunta
resulta ser estadística
vamos con la siguiente pregunta ésta
dice tengo
y por supuesto esta es una pregunta muy
importante de hecho yo ya empiezo a
tener hambre pero solo nos habla de
sensaciones verdad no esa no nos está
hablando de datos está esta pregunta
sólo se puede responder con un sí o no
verdad y ahí no hay nada de variabilidad
así que esta pregunta no es estadística
muy bien ahora bien vamos con la
siguiente dice cuántos dientes tiene mi
madre y digamos que yo voy con mi madre
y abro su boca y empiezo a contar que
hay 30 dientes muy bien entonces aquí
volvemos a tener una situación parecida
como la de la toronja verdad en donde
realmente no hay variabilidad porque
solamente tenemos un dato verdad a lo
mejor si nos preguntáramos bueno cuántos
dientes tienen en promedio mi familia
pues tendría que contar los dientes que
tiene mi madre los dientes que tiene mi
abuelita que a lo mejor ya son menos los
dientes que tienen mi hermano y así
sucesivamente y entonces sí tendríamos
variabilidad verdad
en este caso no no hay variabilidad
vamos a ver el siguiente caso dice
cuánto tiempo gastan al año mis
familiares para comer muy bien entonces
digamos que mi primer familiar digamos
mi madre que tiene 30 dientes digamos
que al año gasta gasta a otros y 813
perdón horas comiendo muy bien y digamos
que ahora le pregunto no sé a mi hermano
y él gasta setecientos treinta y dos
horas comiendo y digamos que una tercera
persona de mi familia gasta solo 300
horas come muy rápido a lo mejor
entonces podemos observar que aquí sí
hay variabilidad y no sólo eso no sólo
hay variabilidad entre las personas
verdad puede ser que cada año gasten un
número distinto de horas para comer
verdad entonces este caso sí hay
variabilidad y entonces podemos decir
que es una pregunta estadística y
finalmente dice cuántas veces he visto
la guerra de las galaxias'
y digamos que a lo mejor yo soy un
aficionado y la he visto siete veces muy
bien sin embargo tenemos un caso similar
como el de los dientes de mi madre y
como el de la toronja verdad solo
tenemos un dato y por lo tanto no hay
variabilidad eso sería distinto si a lo
mejor me preguntara digamos cuántas
veces en promedio ha visto digamos han
visto mis colegas la guerra de las
galaxias' y le pregunto a todos ellos y
resulta hacer que a lo mejor no la ha
visto siete veces a lo mejor alguien
nunca la ha visto a lo mejor otra
persona la ha visto tres veces o solo
una vez entonces ahí hay variabilidad
sin embargo como esta fórmula de esta
pregunta no
ok entonces espero que eso te dé una
idea de cómo se ve la variabilidad
estadística y en sí de que es una
pregunta estadística